there's a recurring theme on the show
death is a big theme yeah so it's always
right around the corner yeah is this
something that it comes from and this
was your concept is this something that
comes from your daily life this
obsession with death yes yes thank you
think about death a lot
I mean constantly and don't we all I
mean it's really I think I do actually
no I really don't think I do think about
it all yeah no you know you're tall so
but for experiences you know we're so
low to the ground already and some
Oteri's work obviously so I just feel
like you know this signs looming up I
mean is it in the bicycles that jump out
on you in the streets sure but more than
that it's in the early onset of fascia
for example you know what was that ah
it's when you play them up with a word
my grasp that's death my back my back
went out no no that's death
it's everywhere see I don't think that
way there's plenty of times where I
can't come up with a word or my
background and I just think I'm gonna be
a huge burden to my family yeah I'm
gonna live a really long time I'm gonna
lose my mind
and my kids and my wife we're gonna have
to clean this mess up yeah and I'm not
going anywhere I'll be around the house
dressed like Captain Crunch and smashing
things and causing all kinds of problems
but I'm just gonna go and go and go
that's what I think yeah all right good
for you can't wait to come visit I
personally hope to become you know part
cyborg but we could talk about that
later really wanna live do you really
want to live a little live a long time I
would not my I just think I'm so
unimpressed with the organs and general
joints all this stuff I'm who goes
around saying I'm unimpressed with
organs that's all we are you know like
this so you know I mean monkey they're
clearly fallible highly and how great
would it be to be like no more that you
know a brain in a box you know in some
sort of as if on body would be ideal
I think parties okay okay all right yeah
right um
you know I will say I well yeah and II
you'll bear witness to this yeah all
right here all the time talking to all
kinds of people you're one of the most
unusual in a delightful way thank you
Tony you are such an interesting person
to talk it's not your the things that
you've said already just tonight you
said 15 things that make absolutely no
sense to me well we're so happy for you
the first season of Russian doll just a
beloved show is streaming now on netflix
if you're not watching it check it out
people are losing their minds for this
program and best of luck to you at the
Emmys I would like to see you up on that
stage and struggling to make a speech
and saying things just like you are
saying tonight regardless of whether you
win or not we want to get up on stage
next to whoever does win if it's not you
I don't trust organs I know how many of
these do you need Dreyfuss